come [ __ ] with me on
uh on instagram just adam devine i uh
i recently changed i was going i had the
pseudonym
of andy bovine i remember which was a
nickname
that i got in high school uh because
adam devine just sounds like a fake name
it just sounded like too cool for with
the spazzy little
you know kid i was so like i was hanging
out with a lot of older kids when i was
like freshman sophomore and like one of
the seniors was like
yo dude your name is no longer adam
devine it's andy bovine
and i'm like hey i also like that
nickname so but then i was getting
people that i
considered like i was friends with them
but like they're hollywood friends so we
don't really see each other that often
we'd see each other at parties
and i remember like uh like i remember
some dude was like um
who i considered a buddy was like hey
andy i want to introduce you to some
someone and i'm like oh and then
like thinking oh he just kind of
misspoke and then he goes hey this is
uh andy bovine this is
no did you go along with it no i called
him out right then i'm like you think my
name is andy beauvoir
like it's wolf blitzer
and he's like he's like yeah and i'm
like oh it's adam divine he goes i
thought adam devine was like your stage
name and your real name is andy bovine
and i'm like
and i gotta just get rid of it so it's
now out of adam divine
on instagram it's like this this is
[Laughter]
yeah dude